Her low freak bitches.
You can whip those people up and get on their frequency and then there's smart
people that can be manipulated.
They can be manipulated once they attach themselves to an ideology.
Yup.
Like we were talking about like people on the left that are avoiding all the
craziness about Hillary.
Like you had a quote that I really liked that's on your Twitter.
You know that if like Hillary was a man that had done the all the same things
that she like,
what is the quote?
What does it your exact,
I see,
remember I said a,
if Hillary was a male republican with the exact same voting record,
all of her supporters would hate her with a passion.
Yeah,
it's true.
And it's 100% sure.
100% true.
I mean it's not,
this is not controversial in any way,
shape or form.
Hillary is is,
you know,
I mean the stuff I was saying before,
but she's,
she's like courting the left.
She's courting people who are supposed to be liberals and you'll go,
she's supported every single war of my lifetime,
every single war.
Well now they know they can get past that.
She didn't support gay marriage up until 2013 even their pet issues.
Yeah,
it's,
she's,
she's a weird one man.
She's a really,
really weird one.
That fucking Libya thing.
We came,
we saw,
he died
like,
that's okay.
Like are you kidding me?
What you remember when,
uh,
the fucking Vermont Guy Screamed?
I know I got to
Howard Dean and that one yell did men it,
that's it.
They saw it and they're like,
fuck this guy.
We,
we came,
we saw he died.
Ha ha ha.
Like that doesn't,
you don't think that lady is fucking crazy.
You don't think that ladies fucking cars.
I mean,
you're down for her.
That's,
that is a completely an ideology thing.
You,
she's,
she's on your team.
You're going to,
you're going to go along with it just like it's a religion.
Just like you're,
you're subscribing to some predetermined thing.
It's,
it's,
it's just,
it's weird for me to see,
first of all,
it's weird that she wants to be president.
Like,
aren't you old?
Like you're an old lady.
How much energy do you have?
Got a ton of money.
You just had your first grandkid.
You've got like perspective,
like what it'll you're trying to do.
We're trying to make history as a woman.
Is that what it is?
I mean,
do you want to just like get back at your husband for getting his Dick Sucked
and in 1991 or whatever the fucking was?
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't even think it's that.
I think it's,
it's,
I mean,
who knows who I,
you know,
I'm not in their head,
but I think these people are like power brokers that just want more and more of
it and it's a real,
it is probably a thrill unlike anything we could imagine to have that much power
and they've,
they've tasted a little bit of that,
you know?
Yeah.
Just,
it seems to me that she's like so old that she would just want to chill,
you know?
It just doesn't make any sense to me.
She's,
she's an old lady.
Like she doesn't have good health.
I think that was the other thing that concerned with,
she had some health issues.
Right then she had like concussions or something.
Yeah.
There was hit in the head.
I forget what it was,
but it was to beat the fuck out of our imagine.
Turns out that bill just wailed on her and she wants to keep it quiet until
fucking Kot.
He's been accused of violence.
Wow.
She has suffered from fainting spells since at least 2005 and that year she
passed out presumably so,
or while giving a speech in 2012 she passed out yet again and suffered a
concussion.
Holy Fuck.
Presumably sober is something that if they ever have to say it,
it's just not good.
Yeah.
You got issues.
We're always presumably sober.
I'm not usually pursuing,
but all right.
You know,
but this idea that she fell asleep and and hit her fucking head,
like when people fall and hit their head,
it's one of the worst things about getting knocked out is not getting punched in
the head.
It's you falling down and getting hit in the head with the earth.
Yeah.
Like their,
their heads bounce off the ground.
That's like a big issue in street fights and stuff.
When you watch someone get sucker punched,
they will fall down in their head,
gets bounced off the curb.
And I think people who have like epilepsy and things like that,
like that's the big fairly,
what happens is that that you end up cracking your head on the ground.
It's not just the seizure seizures.
Um,
yeah,
there's,
there's something,
I don't know,
Hillary Clinton said recently,
and this would probably be one of the tactics she tries to use against Trump,
but she said something along the gut.
She goes,
you know,
I just,
I,
I don't know if he's the type of guy we would want having control of the nuclear
codes.
And it's just like an interesting thing to look at what your like how crazy is
it that any one person has control of those nuclear codes?
Like we're just counting on one person to not snap,
to not kill the whole world to just,
yeah.
Hopefully you don't ever just like,
I've had enough.
I'm fucking,
yeah.
It's the,
the cigarettes and coffee thing or the staples of the alcoholics,
right?
Yeah.
A lot of,
uh,
a people enjoy those cigarettes and they enjoy those,
those coffees,
but you know,
in their eyes.
Yeah.
But then,
but in their eyes,
they feel like they've got the alcohol part under wraps now because this stuff
just kind of keeps him going and this stuff is not ruining their life.
Right.
Alotta alcohol,
she used cannabis the same way.
Um,
and uh,
that's not really accepted by Aa.
So I know a lot,
a lot of people who have kicked their alcoholism by moving more towards
cannabis,
but again,
within the gay community that they don't like that,
that's still considered a drug.
So,
but you can get it
addicted to anything,
you know,
whether it's set porn or dig MACs or where we can get it,
uh,
psychologically addicted to anything.
But Jamie didn't,
the guy who created,
um,
alcoholics anonymous didn't have positive experiences with LSD.
Okay.
That'd be funny.
That would be,
I feel like,
I feel like you did acid as the only thing you're in that to take guys.
So I feel like,
I feel like,
uh,
that was something that happened like maybe even after.
Okay.
Well,
I don't want to speak out of school.
Yeah,
my right.
I'll pull it up.
Yeah.
So what the fuck?
Well,
that's why the government needs to live testing.
Oh,
on a lot of things.
So we know.
Scroll that up please.
Alcoholics anonymous foe a founder believed LSD could cure alcoholism.
Wow.
You've seen so much research now in psychedelics that clinics are opening up.
There's a clinic in,
in La for,
for Acadamin,
you know,
and you're seeing NDNA clinics opening up.
What?
Most of them do not realize that the program's cofounder,
Bill Wilson credited the psychedelic drugs LSD for alleviating his alcoholism
and believe the drug could be used to treat others as well.
Holy Shit.
So those friends of bill,
they didn't get all the information [inaudible] of bill.
If you're in the alcoholics anonymous,
right?
That's what they call themselves.
Like Ken's a bill.
It's like the code w but they didn't get that experience.
It's kind of like the mushrooms,
like quitting cigarettes.
Yeah.
But do you think they tell them,
I never heard this before today.
How could you not tell these people?
Wilson first became,
uh,
began experimenting with Lsd in Los Angeles at the Veterans Administration back
in 1956.
But after taking his first hit of acid,
he realized that it was not the aspect of terror that could help remedy
alcoholism,
but rather the insight one could attain from stepping into a world of simulated
insanity.
And whoa.
Wilson believe that using the LSD could help the alcoholic discover a power
greater than ourselves that in turn could restore us to sanity.
However,
he was adamant that using acid to combat the demons of alcoholism was not
something that he could,
that one could expect from a single dose.
He's like more research is required and snacks.
Wow.
Hmm.
That's interesting,
man.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Psychedelics,
I think as we experiment within,
like medically,
I going to reveal some secrets.
This guy's,
this guy's a heavy duty tripper.
They're going further down.
He was tripping with Aldous Huxley.
Like this guy.
This isn't like one experience he had.
Interesting.
There's documentation that indicates Wilson was involved with many supervise LSD
trials,
including some with psychology,
a psychologist,
Betty Eisner and brave new world author,
Aldous Huxley,
which led them to believe that the visions and insights given by l LSD could
create a large incentive,
at least in a considerable number of people.
And so this was with like a leader,
and in fact,
they lift the left this out of the AA pamphlet.
How do they,
how could they leave this out?
That's crazy.
Cause this seems like this had to play a major part in this guy's ability to
kick alcohol
[inaudible].